hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
this puzzle was sent with the dubious
claim that only a genius could solve it
but it's still a fun logic problem so
let's try and work it out
a number lock has a digit code can you
crack the code from the following hints
682
one number is correct and in the correct
position
645 one number is correct but in the
wrong position
206 two numbers are correct but in the
wrong positions
738 nothing is correct
7 8 0 one number is correct but in the
wrong position
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we figure this problem out
well rather than working from the top
clue down to the bottom
i like to try and find a clue that gives
the most information
so personally for me i would start with
the fourth clue that 738 nothing is
correct
this means we can eliminate all three
numbers 7 3 and 8 from all of the
possibilities
so when we look at all of the other
numbers we know that wherever we see an
8 or a 7 or a 3
we can say that cannot be the correct
number
so now let's just start working from the
first clue
we know that one number is correct and
in the correct position but 8 is not a
correct number
this means either two is correct or six
is correct
but they're both not correct otherwise
we'd have two correct numbers
now let's combine this information with
the second clue that six four five one
number is correct but in the wrong
position
if 6 was in the correct position in 682
it would also be in the correct position
in 645
so 6 cannot be correct and that means 2
is correct and correctly positioned in
six eight two
so we've eliminated six as a possible
number and
two has to be correct and in the third
spot
now from the second clue we know that
six is not a correct number and we know
one number is correct so either 4 is
correct or 5 is correct but not both
now we go to the third clue
well we know 6 is not a correct number
and we have two correct numbers
so that means both 2 and 0 are correct
numbers but they're in the wrong
positions
from 6a2 we know that 2 is in the third
position and since 0 is in the wrong
position in 206 that means 0 must
actually be correct in the first
position so the code has to look
something like 0
blank 2.
so how do we get that final third number
let's take a look at this clue again
the code is either 0 4 2 or 0 5 2.
if the code was 0 4 2 then 645 would
have a number in the correct position
but it does not
therefore the code must be 0 5 2
and that's the correct answer
0 5 2 is the correct combination
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos which can be watched for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 100 million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can map
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
math topic presh and
mindyourdecisions.com and if you so
choose you can check out my books which
are listed in the video description and
you can support me on patreon for
exclusive rewards thanks for watching
and thanks for your support